le score au tableau d'affichage est
lourd ce dimanche 13 mai plaisir
s'incline à domicile 33 24 dans une
rencontre où les jaune et noir n'ont
jamais pu trouver la solution face à
l'entente pelé cnc genre de match voilà
faut vraiment être à 200 % si on veut
l'emporter
alain moindre relâchement et on prend
trois quatre buts d'écart et un deuxième
relâchement et voilà on termine à moins
9 mais bon blessé le mérite amplement
cette victoire
donc je savais que c'était un match un
match difficile on avait perdu à l'aller
chez une bonne équipe
aucun fond de jeu cohérent donc je
m'attendais à un match difficile mais
après on s'attend jamais à à perdre
cette troisième défaite en quatre
matches disputés dans le championnat de
nationale 3 fait redescendre plaisir à
la quatrième place
une spirale négative dans le sprint
final qui peut s'expliquer par le nombre
de blessés dans les rangs plaisir war
c'est sûr que cette année on a un
effectif qui fait que si on perd un ou
deux joueurs sur des postes clés voilà
on a un déficit sur le point de vue
défensif où le dispositif qu on a line
sont pas les dispositifs qu'on aligne
habituellement donc forcément on essaye
de trouver des solutions là où
finalement il n'a peut-être pas et voilà
mais bon c'est juste parce qu'on essaye
de rester compétiteurs jusqu'au bout et
de se battre avec nos armes quoi
l'entraîneur victor garrigues espère
récupérer un maximum de joueurs d'ici le
prochain match programmé ce dimanche 20
mai à l'extérieur sur le terrain de
saint sébastien sport avec toujours un
objectif en tête
accrocher une place de barragiste à la
fin de la saison